okay let's get into audience questions
the first one one that i am asked so
often david why does it appear to be
more profitable to be a right-wing
grifter
than it does to be a left-wing grifter
either someone who
pretends to have changed sides or have a
political awakening or simply put out
ideas that even they don't believe
merely because it makes money there are
two reasons why
right wing grifting is so much more
popular than left wing grifting
the uh the the two reasons are number
one
the left doesn't really care about
people who have these opposite
supposed awakenings or come to
realize that what they've been fed by
their side is wrong or whatever the left
doesn't care about it in the same
way and number two there's just less
money available on the left for it so
we'll explain these one by one the idea
of someone who used to be on the left
and now is on the right as someone we
should pay particular attention to
is much more exciting to the right the
left doesn't care
people call into the show all the time
and say i had an awakening
i'm on the left now i used to be a right
winger i fell down the rabbit hole
it's interesting in the sense that i'm
curious how did you get out because we
know it's tough to get out
but my reaction is a very muted oh so
you looked at the facts and now you
better understand things you're no
longer falling for propaganda
you now understand the real world and so
of course now you're on the same side
i'm on which is the site of empiricism
and facts and so on and so forth
now let's try to get something done
let's get the right people elected let's
try to fix some some problems in society
what you see on the right is completely
different when dave rubin
supposedly had an awakening from being a
bernie guy
to saying liberalism is a mental
disorder he was
ushered into prageru to do a video about
how he left the left
when candace owens i mean candace owen's
story is a little more nuanced because
for identity reasons she's also really
interesting to the right but
she has this story it may be real it may
be not how she grew up in a democratic
house and i think it was connecticut or
whatever and then she figured out all
these things
the right sees that and they celebrate
it in some kind of defiant heroic
reaction whereas the left when when it
happens just says oh you were you were
uninformed great now
now you're now you're with us but let's
go to the next thing
it's not it's just not as interesting to
the audiences and
case in point many people may not
remember
jenk yuger has taught host to the young
turks has talked about how
when he was young he was a reactionary
conservative republican he was i think
in the republican
club in college whatever every once in a
while it comes up but it essentially has
nothing to do with the success of the
young turks like the young turks or not
it's not predicated on this heroic
awakening that jenk had which could be a
grift or it might not and he
was like yeah it seems pretty clear he
was kind of a moderate republican in
in college and now he's not okay that's
it so the right creates cults of
personality around these people
in the way that left doesn't and it
makes it really appealing financially
okay second piece money
there just is more money available for
this stuff
on the right than there is on the left
i'll i've i've seen it firsthand and
we've dealt with all sorts of different
groups and
there just is on the right there are
tons of well-funded groups
that love to throw money at people who
are
doing the grift so to speak um these
libertarian groups that pay to bring
people to college campuses and you can
get
nice speaking fees uh depending on your
level your profile
you know the speaking fee can can be
more or less there really isn't much of
that
on the left uh the few times i've been
paid to speak at colleges it was that
the college had like a donor-funded
thing of
let's bring people to speak there were
never groups
in fact whenever i get invited by
left-leaning groups they say we have no
money
um organizations that then will
fund you know interview series on
different programs and these types of
things
uh donations as well even just
soliciting
the enlightened centrism tim poole as an
example who raised
a ton of money as someone who said he
was like mostly a bernie guy and all
this stuff but
then 90 percent of his content became
criticizing the left and praising trump
he raised a whole bunch of money with
the idea that he
who had he was on one side but he sees
this and the other and now he's got this
whole nice
neat little package as the arbiter of
what's what's right and what's wrong
um he was able to raise a ton of money
on the idea of launching
such a website that would just give you
the news
tm some they figured out how to do the
news and people donated like crazy to it
that appeals to
to right wingers um and i know someone
will say oh left i'm a left winger i
donated to that okay fine but
the the left does not reward that that
stuff that type of grifting um
ideologically
in terms of the cults of personality
around people
nor financially that's the explanation
as i see it that's the explanation as
i've
experienced it from within and remember
i told the story
of this radio consultant who met with me
years ago and said you know
do you really care about like what
you're saying because if you just want
to be a performer
there is a need right now for shows like
yours or you know
at the time a really young guy but on
the right i could get you syndicated and
we could triple your salary
and i've told that story before there
was no such thing available to me on the
left
um and i'm glad i turned it down and
everything worked out fine no regrets
whatsoever so those are my thoughts on
the profitability
of the left-wing grift versus the
right-wing grift or the lack thereof
when it comes to the left-wing grift
send me more thoughts about what you
think might uh explain that difference